so in this particular Class A very very
very important topic that we are going
to talk is about transportation of
substances through plasma membrane in
site and outside of the cell it is
always movement of molecules from the
higher concentration to lower
concentration right the concentration of
perfume is more where it is more in the
bottle and as soon as you open it it
just diffuses in the air right osmosis
is actually possible in three conditions
what are those High concentration to low
concentration but via a semi-permeable
membrane hypertonic means inside there
is more water than outside outside the
soil concentration is more so oh